[Music]
in this video we're going to walk
through how to manage member permissions
for your google cloud billing account
to manage member permissions you'll need
to be a billing account administrator on
the billing account
get started by heading into the console
then head to the navigation menu in the
left-hand pane
choose billing then use the drop-down
menu to select manage billing accounts
select the billing account for which
you'd like to manage members and
permissions
this will open the overview page in the
left-hand nav
choose account management to the right
you will see the info panel where you
can view the list of current members
edit their permissions or remove them
you can also add new members
permissions are bundled to form several
functional roles
billing account administrators can view
cost information
link and unlink projects from the
account and manage
other member roles on the account they
are also the only ones who can contact
google
cloud support if you need help billing
account costs managers can view all cost
details
including project costs and non-project
related costs such as the cost of
support or subscriptions
they can also manage budgets and export
cost information
to bigquery for analysis billing account
viewers can view all cost details for
the billing account
and view but not edit budgets and
bigquery export settings
billing account users can link projects
with the billing account
these role assignments are made at the
billing account level
however there are also billing related
roles at the organization
folder and project levels you can set
roles at these levels by navigating to
the project
folder or organization from the project
selector
and then to the iam page where you can
view current members
and add new members and roles at the
project or folder level
project billing managers can assign a
project's billing account
when they have the billing account user
role on the target billing account
they can also disable a project's
billing at the organization level
billing account creators can create new
self-serve billing accounts
it is a good idea to minimize the number
of members who have this role in order
to better manage your organization's
billing accounts and spend
you can also set the roles that we
discussed earlier such as billing
account administrator
user and viewer at the organization
level and the permissions will apply to
all the cloud billing accounts
projects and resources in the
organization
head over to the documentation to check
out more details
you